es el momento que francia había estado
esperando el astronauta francés
convertido en héroe nacional toma pesqué
salió de la cápsula dragón de spacex el
último de la tripulación de cuatro
personas en hacerlo es un orgullo haber
representado a francia una vez más en el
espacio la próxima vez la luna
finalmente tenemos que volver a la
tierra para asegurarnos primero y
después tomar un pequeño descanso la
cápsula aterrizó el lunes por la tarde
-hora local- frente a la costa de
florida fue transportada por barcos y
los astronautas llevados de vuelta a
tierra en un helicóptero el amerizaje
fue la culminación de un viaje de meses
a la estación espacial internacional el
equipo compuesto por dos estadounidenses
un astronauta japonés y pes que mejoró
en los paneles solares y realizó cientos
de experimentos incluyendo la
documentación de la superficie cambiante
de la tierra debido a la actividad
humana y el cultivo de pimientos en el
espacio por primera vez aunque es el
final de la travesía de la tripulación
en el espacio es el comienzo de un viaje
de 45 días de rehabilitación ya que
deben real a la vida en la tierra el
veterano astronauta misil touring y
conoce pie las dificultades que les
esperan permaneceremos en posición
vertical durante una o dos horas como
máximo después nos acostaremos para que
el cuerpo se acostumbre a la gravedad
terrestre y todo será muy difícil al
principio porque tu cuerpo es muy pesado
tu brazo pesará una tonelada las piernas
son muy muy pesadas no te sentirás bien
y tendrás náuseas o nariz newsbeat
spacex comenzó a llevar astronautas a la
estación espacial internacional el año
pasado poniendo fin a casi una década de
dependencia de eeuu de los cohetes rusos
después de que el programa del
transbordador espacial de la nasa
terminara